If you want to hear my two fan theories about
the upcoming movie Glass, then stick around
to the end of this video.
I just watched the trailer for Glass.
This has got to be my most anticipated movie
of all time.
If this movie is good, this could be the greatest
trilogy ever.
So.
As you can imagine, I've got a lot to talk
about here.
Please, do yourself a favor.
Make sure you've seen these movies before
you watch this video.
The trailer opens by introducing us to Dr.
Ellie Staple, a psychiatrist who specializes
in individuals who believe that they are superheroes.
Now in Split, there a psychiatrist named Dr.
Fletcher, who works with The Horde.
One of the many personalities asks Dr. Fletcher
what would happen to them if she were to pass
away, and this is her response.
"If ever something were to happen to me, I've
made arrangements with a colleague from Baltimore
to take over."
What if this Dr. Staple is the colleague from
Baltimore?
The name of the asylum, as seen on this nametag
later in the trailer, is Raven Hill Memorial.
Baltimore was the home of Edgar Allan Poe,
who wrote the famous poem The Raven, and of
course the NFL team, The Ravens, reside there.
But this movie does, like almost all of Shyamalan's
films including Split and Unbreakable, take
place in Philadelphia.
Next we see some shots from around the asylum,
including this one, from Kevin's room.
You can tell because of the 24 toothbrushes.
Also, at the beginning of this shot, the lights
are off and all we see are these three panes
of glass.
That could come to represent the three main
characters.
Not long after, we are shown those three characters:
all together in the same room.
Perhaps the most shocking part though, is
that David Dunn is the only one who's chained
up.
The big question is going to be: what did
he do to become a criminal?
This could be a situation similar to The Incredibles,
where his acts of heroism also cause damage.
Cause he does just kind of walk into people's
houses uninvited.
Later in the trailer this appears to be his
arrest scene.
And then later on he seems to be surrendering,
and the removal of his raincoat is a symbol
of him showing weakness during his arrest,
because in Unbreakable, water is essentially
is his Kryptonite.
There's also this woman who's holding stop
signs, possibly David's wife, or possibly
Doctor Staple.
Back to this shot though, I'm guessing that
Elijah simply doesn't need to be chained up
because he isn't a physical threat.
But if they've now captured The Horde, you'd
think he would be chained up as well.
Pay attention to the order they are sitting
in, because in the next shot, there are some
books propped up in the comic book store.
The Legion of Regrettable Super Villains is
the book on the left.
The League of Regrettable Superheroes on the
right and there’s something in the middle,
I can't tell what book it is, but it probably
represents The Horde.
There's also something off to the side here.
If the bad guys are teaming up in this movie,
maybe David teams up with a new character
as well.
For record, I don't consider Kevin to be a
bad guy, but out of the 24 personalities that
reside in his body, at least three of them
are bad and I think that's what Elijah refers
to when he says that line about the bad guys
teaming up.
This scene is very reminiscent of the comic
store scene in Unbreakable where Elijah has
the epiphany about David Dunn having a weakness.
The character in the comic he's looking at
has a resemblance to The Beast, the 24th personality
in Split.
But with hair.
This panel of him bending the bars is just
like The Beast bending the bars of the cage
at the end of Split.
And just to break down this page, these two
are in some kind of danger when the beast
guy comes in and grabs the bars.
He says, "what they've done to us is unforgivable.
I vowed to protect everyone from..." something...
it's too blurry to read at that point.
But then he breaks through the bars, the villain
says "time for me to get out of here", and
the beast goes after these yellow eyes in
the dark.
And his last quote is "I don't know how much
longer I can keep chasing him ..." I think
it's likely that we'll see a scene similar
to this in Glass.
Perhaps the character in this comic doesn't
represent The Beast, but rather David Dunn.
If that's the case, maybe him breaking out
of the bars corresponds to this, and "I don't
know how much longer I can keep chasing him..."
refers to him getting older.
Before we move on from this page of comics,
they cut the trailer to make it look like
Elijah Price is the one reading this comic,
but I don't think those are his hands.
OK, this shot shows David Dunn in a diner
/ casino, and because I know people are going
to ask, no it's not the same diner as the
end of Split.
There is, however, a news report on the screen
showing something going down at Osaka Tower,
which I'm guessing is supposed to be a building
in Osaka, Japan.
So I think Mr. Glass is up to his old tricks
again once he inevitably escapes.
Next shot.
David bumps into this guy, whose face we can't
see at first.
After a quick flashback of these chained up
cheerleaders, we see that it's Kevin... or
at least one of the personalities, but which
one?
It could be Dennis, who is stated in Split
to have a thing for watching young girls dance
naked.
But it could be Hedwig, who is the owner of
that jacket and loves listening to music.
OK, fine.
Roll it.
Uh, Hedwig would probably be the only to wear
his headphones outside his hood like that.
But if that is Hedwig, I guess that means
either Hedwig is complicit, like he was in
the kidnapping of the girls in Split, or David
can see the actions of the entire Horde by
bumping into Kevin's body.
By the way, the position that the girls are
chained up in almost looks to be a callback
to the way the Janitor tied up those girls
in Unbreakable.
In Glass, we'll get to see a bunch of new
personalities that had files on the computer
in Split, but who never actually made an appearance
in the light, such as Mary Reynolds...
"I'm Mary Reynolds."
Someone who speaks Spanish...
"Por favor.
Señor!"
And apparently Logan Paul?
"We almost got you bro!"
When Mr Glass is talking about his brittle
bone disease, we see this X-Ray. from July
1999.
Now Unbreakable came out in 2000 and could
take place in '99.
This could be the very same X-Ray from that
fall down the stairs at the subway.
However, I don't think that's the reason he's
still in a wheelchair now, because in Unbreakable,
the doctor tells him he'll be in the wheelchair
for a couple months and then be on crutches
after that.
Split takes place 15 years after Unbreakable,
and I imagine Glass takes place shortly after
Split, because there is a brief shot later
in the trailer here where The Beast looks
to still have his gunshot wounds from Split.
Also, Mr. Glass’s crutches do make an appearance
at the end of the trailer, so maybe he won't
be wheelchair bound for the entirety of the
third one.
Like some people.
There's a brief shot in the trailer of a crowded
room, with almost no context, but if you pay
attention to this sign, you'll notice it's
a train station.
Trains are significant in both films, in Unbreakable,
its David's survival of a train accident,
or I guess I should say train wreck, that
first gets Elijah's attention; and he also
searches for criminals by bumping into them
at the train station.
In Split, the train yard is where Dennis goes
to unleash The Beast.
And it's also mentioned that the root of his
disorder has something to do with his Dad
leaving on a train when he was very young.
Fan theory, I'm going to say that the train
his Dad was on was the same train derailed
at the beginning of Unbreakable.
This is a very interesting shot.
At one point in the trailer we see Casey from
Split reaching out to the Horde.
Here, we see her leaving the asylum with Elijah
Price's mom from Unbreakable, and David Dunn's
son Joseph Dunn, who is all grown up now.
Could Joseph possibly be the owner of this
comic shop, whose face is conveniently hidden?
And as a side note, this character, whoever
he is, seems to be making a symbolic choice
between Heroes and Villains.
That brings me to fan theory number two.
Roll the clip.
"May I meet The Beast?
I hope for your sake that he likes you.
That sounds like the bad guys teaming up."
I think The Beast does end up liking Mr. Glass
for the same reason he likes Casey in Split,
because he is physically broken and the in
the eyes of The Beast, that makes him pure,
unlike David, who is...
And speaking of Unbreakable, after this shot
where two nurses are running away from the
asylum and David Dunn can be seen in his raincoat
in the background, the trailer ends with imagery
of broken glass.
Christmas is coming late this year.
In January.
I mean, technically that's next year, but
you get my point.
If you are stoked for this movie, if you are
ready to complete the Unbreakable trilogy,
let me know by leaving this video a like.
Let me know your theories about Glass in the
comments.
"They say this one has a surprise ending."
And finally, if you're interesting in seeing
Things You Missed videos on Unbreakable, Split
and Glass, make sure you're subscribed to
CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.